also leute hot spicy oder wie es hat
nichts mit chili bio apfel faser und
meersalz hey was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich euch jedes gut heute
mal nach langer zeit wieder mit stativ
aber ich hab mir gedacht das ist
eigentlich für so ein video gar kein
problem wir haben zwar keinen hinter der
kamera
aber ich glaube eben und ich habe mir
gerade noch so ein kamel gemacht das
heißt heute auf entspannt so das thema
ist aber trotzdem sehr sehr cool und
zwar durfte ich mir wieder ein paar neue
adventskalender aussuchen und heute
machen wir einen auf ich weiß auch schon
was drin ist es ist nämlich ein popcorn
adventskalender mit 24 verschiedenen
popcorn sorten das hat mich brutal
interessiert weil ich kenne eine popcorn
sorte und das ist halt popcorn gut dann
vielleicht noch popcorn mit salz aber
das war's dann auch schon
naja gut der ist ganz schön schwer alter
das auf jeden fall der schwerste bis
jetzt hauptkommissar wand ganz so schwer
also dann würde ich sagen machen wir den
markt also auch an dieser stelle wieder
schöne grüße an boxee land die ja diese
ganzen kalender befüllen die ein sehr
viel mit menschen mit handicap zusammen
also ich habe ja schon oft genug gesagt
darum nach oben hier und kalender
natürlich wie immer auch in der video
bestellung verlegt wobei wir haben bald
schon den ersten dezember das heißt ja
man müsste sich jetzt auch anhalt mit
kalender kaufen und es sieht natürlich
wie immer
[Musik]
alter ist er schwer ziemlich nein ich
habe was ist denn da drin wie immer ein
cooles design bot im fresh popcorn extra
large ich bin gespannt was mich jetzt
erwartet wie ich auch schon den letzten
videos gesagt habt ihr könnt mir auch
sehr gerne immer kalender schicken die
ich damit stellen werde falls sie mich
überzeugen nicht so standard dinge ich
habe ganz viele standards zeug bekommen
da brauche ich nicht ein bisschen
schokolade drin ist es ja langweilig hat
irgend jemand von euch zufälligerweise
schon die 1 gefunden
falls nicht gar kein problem ich habe es
nämlich schon gefunden und zwar hier
oben
soll ich jetzt 24 mal popcorn noch leute
was geht ab herzlich willkommen zurück
ich musste gerade einen kleinen kampf
machen und zwar habe ich trottel
eigentlich gedacht hier werden halt so
fertige kleine popcorn verpackung drin
da ich nicht kräftig geehrt
aber das war ein dummer gedanke
eigentlich von mir weil so wie es jetzt
ist ist es vielleicht sogar
interessanter ich habe nämlich jetzt
herausgefunden wir haben in jedem fall
braucht layout und immer ein spezielles
gewürzt wie zb müsse snowman popcorn
gewürz zubereitung und ich habe jetzt
halt gedacht wir machen dann erstmal nur
kurz auf und dann werde ich am ende des
videos drei oder fünf popcorn sorten sag
ich mal kurz selber zubereiten und die
dann probieren weil ich habe auch noch
nie popcorn müsse snowman gegessen mit
bio apfel faser zitronen pulver deswegen
ich mache jetzt im schnelldurchlauf
einfach mal alles auf weil alles andere
sei langweilig
[Musik]
ich ziehe mir direkt hier um die 24 aus
weil die muss sich ja eigentlich
aufzubereiten bio dark berry popcorn
gehört zubereitungen dark berry alles
klar
schwarze johannisbeere also das machen
wir schon mal saved also ist wird die 24
das muss ja gemacht werden spies limango
supreme court mix alter hier sind chilis
drin
das könnte ich auch probieren ich denke
ich mir auch schon mal zur seite kakao
kaffee alte auch geil
es muss ja nicht auch machen nicht gut
ich kann auch nicht alles machen weil
das dauert viel zu lang
football okay das kriegt nicht so
interessant
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich auch schon die nächste
reihe leer gezogen
hier haben war indianer dream aus
koriander kurkuma und hernach schmeckten
das dann also ich kann mir gar nicht
vorstellen wie dieses also klar als
schmeckt koriander und so weiter aber ob
das zusammenpasst so popcorn
naja ok lege ich noch mal zur seite wir
haben auch sie zwei rapper love italien
leib paprika rosmarin oregano basilikum
also ein leichter pizza geschmack gut
das liegt mir auch noch zur seite bio
sommergarten biohotels smoby okay so bio
homepage teile aus also man muss schon
sagen viele zutaten sind ähnlich also
ich lese jetzt schon hier zum bestimmt
fünften mal apfel faser meersalz habe
ich auch schon öfter gelesen paprika
jetzt auch schon zum dritten mal
also die kombinieren da wahrscheinlich
so insgesamt zehn bis zwanzig zutaten
miteinander und dann entsteht heute
immer eine neue sorte ist aber auch eine
coole idee auf jeden fall ja schon
wieder halt paprika mango pulver himbeer
pulver apfel faser gut das klingt
eigentlich auch ganz leicht das werde
ich auch noch nach aus und zu guter
letzt mister snowman haben wir natürlich
auch noch ich habe jetzt hier insgesamt
fünf ausgewählt jetzt müssen wir hier
mal 4 rautschka kopfwäsche marseille
die 24 auf zählt die 24 auch state ja
gut das hier ist auch wieder mit chili
das brauche ich nicht unbedingt und hier
haben wir merken dass das mal aus das
heißt wir haben jetzt hier bio in dem
dream dark berry pop mix und kakao
kaffee also wirklich auch eine popcorn
variante mit skis durch stellt sie war
aus einer küche kann natürlich sein
das ist bei euch daraus irgendwelche
popcorn expertin gibt ich mache es jetzt
so wie es früher auch gemacht habe also
ein bisschen butter dann halt diese
mischung der rein und dann kommt auch
schon der meister und dann der deckel
drauf und dann müsste nicht so klopp ich
hoffe es funktioniert auch
naja wird schon irgendwie klappen jetzt
stellt sich nur die frage womit fangen
wir an ich würde gern mit diesem hort
nix anfangen also mit chili und so
deswegen ja ein bisschen komm mal runter
hier ich tue jetzt mal nicht alles rein
richter auf jeden fall schon sehr
interessant und jetzt kommt der
meisterei kommen das reich deckel drauf
ich müsste jetzt wirklich anfangen zu
kloppen
das ist eigentlich noch offen und das
plateau schuhen versteckt ja gut also
ich warte ab bis es fertig ist dann
zeige ich euch und dann schauen wir mal
ich das weiß was ich mag es juristisch
sauter heute ein 2
man muss warten bis es auch hier zu
bleiben und habe ich ein problem das
fliegt dann bist du deckel war ja ein
bisschen ein bisschen wo das neue e10
tanken
das ist so das sieht ja eigentlich schon
mal nicht schlecht aus und würde ich mal
sagen also leute holt ein spicy oder wie
es ist hat nichts mit chili bio apfel
faser und meersalz
also ist schon hart war das feuer am
anfang dachte ich es wäre nicht so
scharf aber es ist schon fast das
schaffen gut es gibt stars in den usa
bietet ein komplettes popcorn selbst
machen können ist mit allen möglichen
geschmeckt vielleicht sollten wir das in
deutschland aufgehalten und also dass
hier kann ich euch schon mal nicht so
empfehlen aber es war cool das mal zu
probieren ja aber ist jetzt mein
geschmack
das schild das print voll irgendwie wenn
man es eine art macht als nächstes habe
ich jetzt hier im topf kakao kaffee mit
bisschen chili nach unten drunter also
das könnte eigentlich auch ganz leis
werden dass hier
ich kann echt nicht weiter ist leider
dass man hier viel zu scharf ok also als
nächstes haben wir jetzt hier
popcorn kaffee kakao ist ein bisschen an
gebrutzelt aber keine panik ich
probier's mal aber die sehen jetzt nicht
besonders auf
irgendwie alle ich muss auch sagen hallo
herr schmecken nach kaffee das schmeckt
mal so ein bisschen aber so ganz bayern
ist auch nicht naja da noch zwei gute
machen wir mal weiter mit dark berry das
soll jetzt so ein bisschen fruchtiger
werden
da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt ich will
das jetzt gar nicht mehr mit weil das ja
auch langweilig und wenn ich fertig habt
man muss auch sagen in der wohnung es
wichtig schon so leicht verbrannt
nachdem komischen so zutaten so muss man
sagen ja naja okay leute warten manchmal
hier mal kurz das mit dem geruch müssen
gleich martin kopfschmerzen des todes
okay leute als nächstes haben wir jetzt
ein bisschen bio darf very popcorn
das sollte jetzt ein bisschen fruchtiger
schmecken ich hoffe dass du es auch war
er bis jetzt war ich noch nicht so ganz
überzeugt
also ist auf jeden fall deutlich besser
als chili und kaffee aber so ganz toll
ich auch nicht um die muss ich ehrlich
sagen da bin ich dann doch lieber bei
meinem standard zucker popcorn
ich weiß nicht wie leute es ist aber auf
jeden fall meine erfahrung werde das mal
auszuprobieren weil ich habe jetzt noch
nie so probiert und dafür mache ich
diese videos ja auch deswegen will ich
sagen ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
wir haben da jetzt noch irgendwie ein
grund ist aber indischen drin was war
das noch ein keine ahnung dass man jetzt
nicht langsam nach oben da steht mir
weitere adventskalender und für eine
popcorn fans vielleicht ist das ja was
für euch ich habe sich in der video
besteuerung verlinkt bin sogar um alex w
wir sehen uns morgen wieder haut rein